tras unos años de lazos debilitados las
relaciones entre Estados Unidos y
filipinas vuelven a encaminarse los dos
países han anunciado la ampliación de un
acuerdo militar que permitirá a tropas
estadounidenses aumentar su presencia en
el archipiélago nos complace anunciar
hoy que el presidente ferdina Marcos ha
aprobado cuatro nuevos sitios en el
marco del acuerdo de cooperación
reforzada en materia de defensa el
número total de sitios asciende así a 9
el pacto conocido como édca que Data de
2014 no permite una presencia permanente
de tropas estadounidenses su objetivo es
contrarrestar la influencia de china en
la región las bases estratégicas
filipinas a las que tendrán acceso a los
militares estadounidenses se encuentran
en aguas cercanas de Taiwán Isla que
china considera como una provincia
Rebelde y que Washington ha prometido
defender en la eventualidad de un ataque
Beijing ha criticado duramente el
acuerdo y ha acusado a de utilizar a los
países de la zona con objetivos de
desestabilización
por intereses egoístas y un pensamiento
de suma cero Estados Unidos ha ido
aumentando constantemente el despliegue
militar en la región exacerbando las
tensiones regionales y poniendo en
peligro la paz y la estabilidad
regionales
históricos en materia de seguridad pero
bajo la presidencia de Rodrigo duterte
los dos países se habían distanciado
duterte prefirió acercarse a China en
detrimento de Washington una decisión de
revertida por el nuevo gobierno de
Ferdinand Marcos Junior este nuevo
acuerdo llega además en un momento
y otros países de la región una disputa
territorial por el control de las Islas
pratley Beijing reclama la soberanía
sobre casi todo el mar meridional de
China